más
supongamos que queremos ser pintas
robots de cuatro segmentos igual que en
el ejercicio pasado cuántos de esos
robots hay bueno pues tenemos cuatro
opciones para el primer segmento tres
opciones para el segundo segmento dos
opciones para el tercer segmento y una
opción para el cuarto segmento esos son
cuatro por tres por dos por uno y esa
multiplicación es igual a 24 y a poco no
es interesante que podemos hacer 24
distintas serpientes robots utilizando
cuatro objetos distintos y se pone
todavía más interesante imaginemos que
queremos una serpiente robot de 10
segmentos entonces podríamos hacer 10
por 9 por 8 por 7 por 6 por 5 por 4 por
3 por 2 por 1
diferentes combinaciones lo cual nos da
la increíble cantidad de 3 millones 628
mil 800 distintos robots de 10 segmentos
y solo necesitas construir 10 objetos
distintos
este tipo de cálculos aparecen todo el
tiempo en la combinatoria por supuesto
los matemáticos inventaron un nombre y
una abreviación para ellos se llaman
factoriales y se representan con un
símbolo de exclamación por ejemplo 4 con
un símbolo de exclamación o sea 4
factorial significa 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
así es que 4 factoriales 24 5 factorial
es 120 y 10 factorial es más de 3
millones y wow es así que es una
explosión combina tórica de opciones
ahorita mejor hagamos una pausa y
practiquemos este concepto en el próximo
ejercicio